SIERRA: Just for fun, would you be up for
like lightning round ranking the following
popular spy portrayals on a scale of like
1 to 10 for accuracy?
LUCAS: If I've seen them, I'll do my best.
SIERRA: Okay, so obviously, we have to start
with James Bond.
LUCAS: Am I allowed to give negative scores?
SIERRA: Absolutely you are.
LUCAS: I mean, James Bond bears as much relation
to espionage as The Lion King does to natural
history. But it's great for the MI6 brand.
They never complain.
SIERRA: Good recruitment. Okay. What about
The Americans?
LUCAS: I think quite plausible. There are
Russian illegals and from what we know about
them, that wasn't, it's not as exciting as
the Americans but I would give that a six.
SIERRA: Ooh, okay. That's great. What about
the Mission Impossible franchise?
LUCAS: Bambi. I'm surprised you didn t ask
me about the Bourne Identity.
SIERRA: Go ahead, what is it?
LUCAS: I've done Bambi, and I've done The
Lion King. I think this is Pinocchio.
SIERRA: This is why I didn't ask.
Bridge of Spies: In the name of God, why are
we hanging him .he s a spy.
The Spy Who Came In From the Cold: What the
hell do you think spies are? Moral philosophers
measuring everything they do against the word
of God or Karl Marx? They re not.
The Americans: You re going to have to make
a decision to commit to this life or get out.
It s not easy and it doesn t always end well.
SIERRA: Spy content is huge in popular culture.
Ever since the Cold War, the appetite for
spy books, spy movies, and spy shows has been
insatiable. But behind the Hollywood treatment
is a real profession. It consumes billions
of dollars a year, and it fuels the decisions
of world leaders and militaries on a daily
basis. Without it, countries would be left
vulnerable to catastrophe.
And yet it remains deeply misunderstood. Most
of the Hollywood images bear almost no resemblance
to the daily work of the intelligence community,
known to insiders as the IC . The reality
is fascinating, in its own way, and the reality
is also changing in the era of the internet,
spyware, and artificial intelligence. I m
Gabrielle Sierra and this is Why It Matters.
Today, how spying really works.
SIERRA: I think we should start by getting
our terminology in order. What is espionage?
LUCAS: Espionage is finding stuff out, usually
on behalf of governments, and usually involving
some kind of rule-breaking. If it's not involving
rule-breaking, then it's basically journalism.
SIERRA: This is Edward Lucas, he s a journalist
and a Senior Fellow at the Center for European
Policy Analysis. He has written several books
about espionage.
SIERRA: So then, by contrast, what is intelligence?
LUCAS: Intelligence is the product of espionage,
strictly speaking, so you can have raw intelligence,
which is just the stuff that your spies or
your code crackers have found out, and then
that's processed and analyzed, verified, and
then becomes intelligence product, which is
what is sent to decision-makers, for example,
in the Presidential Daily Brief. And then
that hopefully, allows them to make better-informed
decisions about the threats and opportunities
facing their country.
HARDING: Intelligence is this somewhat amorphous
broad concept that means finding the information
that your government needs wherever it happens
to reside, pulling it together, and presenting
it in a usable fashion.
SIERRA: This is Emily Harding. She used to
be an analyst at the CIA, where she eventually
led the Iraq Group. She was also deputy director
of the Senate Select Committee on Intelligence
and worked on its investigation of Russian
interference in the 2016 election. Nowadays
she is a Senior Fellow and Deputy Director
at the Center for Strategic and International
Studies.
HARDING: You want to be able to say hey, there's
this big development out there that's coming
that you need to be ready for. You wanna try
to reduce uncertainty for the policymakers
so that they can try to make the best policies
possible. Espionage is one way to go about
gathering that intelligence. So espionage
is going about stealing the secrets generally
speaking from people. So recruiting an asset
in the field who can do something like, tell
you about the intentions of a foreign government.
Those are often the hardest things to learn
and collect. What is a foreign government
planning to do? What are they intending to
do with their policy? That's not the kind
of thing that you can usually get from open-source
or figure out in other ways. You really need
somebody who's well-placed on the inside to
just tell you these things. And so we have
very well-trained professionals who go all
around the world and try to recruit assets
to conduct espionage.
SIERRA: Spies like jargon. And along the way,
we are going to have to break a bit of that
down for you. So, in the movies, James Bond
will typically break into the enemy headquarters
to steal a key piece of information or technology.
In real life, that s actually not a very effective
strategy. Most real-world spying is done by
assets. That is someone who is already inside
the organization, city, or country you are
spying on. Someone who has access, someone
who blends in. And how do you convince someone
to spy on their own country? Well, that is
the work of an operations officer. These are
the people working for the CIA, or some other
agency, who have the tough job of finding
people to provide or steal secrets. They recruit
them, monitor them, protect them, and when
the time is right, assist them in obtaining
the information. That information is then
funneled back to the CIA, or another agency,
where it is processed by analysts. These are
the people who interpret and piece together
bits of intelligence, kind of like a puzzle.
Each role is important, and each serves a
very specific purpose.
LUCAS: On the whole, espionage is much less
interesting than anything in fiction, because
so much of it takes so long. And so sitting
around waiting for things to happen is a very
important part of the espionage world and
acting very slowly, because mistakes are very
expensive and can be lethal. That doesn't
come across very well when you're looking
at trying to fill a 90 minute Hollywood blockbuster.
SIERRA: No definitely not.
LUCAS: But I suppose the key thing is that
the people who do the spying usually are recruited
by intelligence officers and so the intelligence
officers job is to find a potential source,
to recruit them, to run them, if necessary
to get them out of trouble if they're close
to getting caught. And those are all serious
skills, you have to be really good at doing
that. Actually, stealing the secret may be
a matter of emptying waste paper baskets at
the right time, or sticking a USB drive into
a computer, or doing something other that
can be rather less skilled and less glamorous.
So when we say spying, that encompasses both
the actual stealing of the secret, and then
the huge array of highly trained intelligence
officers who cause all that to happen, and
those are two slightly different things.
SIERRA: So let's zoom out to 30,000 feet just
for a moment. What is the ultimate goal of
espionage? Why do governments need it?
LUCAS: The ultimate goal is better decision-making.
That's the most important thing and then quite
an important secondary goal is to find out
if other countries are spying on you. Because
if they know your secrets, and you don't know
theirs, they will negotiate better.
SIERRA: Intelligence successes typically go
unsung - the Allied forces cracking the Enigma
code during World War II, U.S. intelligence
identifying missiles on Cuba in 1962, and
the CIA predicting the outcome to the 1967
Arab-Israeli War, to name a few. We hear a
lot more about the failures. The 9/11 Commission
Report identified a series of intelligence
shortcomings in the run-up to the attack,
and these failings became a permanent part
of how the tragedy is publically understood.
When intelligence does its job, almost nobody
knows. When it fails, everyone does.
HARDING: Pearl Harbor is the first case study
that they teach you when you come on board
at The Agency as an analyst, where they talk
about why you need intelligence, why you need
intelligence analysts. With Pearl Harbor,
there were a lot of indications and warnings
out there about what the Japanese might be
planning to do, that there was perhaps a large
attack underway. But because that information
was scattered to a bunch of different places
around what was then the Defense Department,
nobody really pulled them all together to
come up with a complete picture and be able
to provide that indication and warning. So
they created the OSS, and the OSS then evolved
to become the CIA. And the goal really was
to take all these little pieces of information,
pull them together for a coherent picture,
and then provide something usable to the policymaker.
A good friend of mine says that intelligence
work is less about connecting the dots and
more about pointillism, like those famous
pieces of artwork. Where you take all these
little tiny pieces of information you have,
and you try to pull them together into a coherent
picture. So that's why we need intelligence.
Some of those dots are open source. Some of
those dots are in the media or discoverable
out there on the internet, but a great many
of them also are highly secret. They come
from those human spies that we were talking
about. They come from signals intelligence
when you pull up conversations or you pull
metadata from electronic communications. And
those kinds of capabilities need to be kept
secret for various reasons. So that's why
we need an intelligence service.
SIERRA: All right. So this sounds like a ton
of people, a ton of steps a lot of time. So
I guess the question is how much does this
all cost?
HARDING: Billions of dollars, but it's a drop
in the bucket compared to the defense budget.
SIERRA: When Emily says billions, she means
billions. In 2020, the intelligence community
appropriated $85.8 billion dollars. That s
a lot, almost four times as much as the government
spent on the space program. But, as Emily
points out, it s only a fraction of the $778
billion that the country spent on overall
defense last year.
HARDING: I think that people tend to focus
on the size of the defense budget and think
about, you know, the big ships and things.
And those are all game-changers in the United
States' security picture, but with the intelligence
community, you get a lot of bang for your
buck. Some collection programs are exceedingly
expensive. You know, we have exquisite satellites
that do really cool things and they cost lots
and lots of money. We also have very low-cost
partnerships with commercial companies that
are collecting satellite imagery as well.
And we put those two pictures together to
come up with a good coherent picture for our
policymakers. So it's expensive. But you definitely
get information that you won t get anywhere
else.
SIERRA: And there are a lot of different organizations
collecting that information. Right now, there
are 18 intelligence agencies within the US,
including Space Force Intelligence, which
was added this year. You may not have even
heard of several of them before, like The
National Geospatial Agency, which used satellite
and drone technology to map Osama Bin Laden's
compound, allowing Navy SEALs to simulate
and prepare for their mission.
HARDING: The way that it works is that there
are intelligence agencies that are connected
to each one of the military services, and
then also small intelligence agencies that
serve kind of a niche function connected to
a bunch of different departments and agencies.
So like the Department of Energy has its own
tiny intelligence service. The Department
of State has its own intelligence service.
And each one of those smaller agencies is
very tightly focused on the needs of the top
customers in their building. On the other
hand, there are also big overarching what
we call all source intelligence agencies like
CIA and DIA, that are looking at all the different
sources of information and trying to pull
them together for a broader customer set.
SIERRA: Along with the Central Intelligence
Agency and the Defence Intelligence Agency,
there s another major player: the NSA, or
National Security Agency. The joke used to
be that those letters stood for no such agency
, because of its extreme secrecy. The NSA
s original purpose was to protect secret messages
from other government agencies and to break
enemy codes. These days it has gotten very,
very good at hacking. With each of these agencies,
there is a constant churn, millions of data
points, thousands of analysts interpreting
what s found. All of it feeding a constant
series of decisions large and small.
?SIERRA: So who uses all of this intelligence?
Is it the President?
HARDING: So the president isn't the biggest
consumer by quantity. The president certainly
gets anything that he wants, gets the most
classified information, the least classified
information. Any question the president has
gets answered. As far as quantity goes, though,
it has to be the US Military. They get both
the tactical intelligence from the battlefield
like, "What's over that next hill? What does
the enemy planning on doing tomorrow? What
IEDs are waiting for us out on the battlefield,"
they get that super tactical intelligence
picture, but then they also get the strategic
intelligence picture like for example, with
the current case of Afghanistan, "Are the
Taliban planning to negotiate in good faith?
What role is Pakistan playing in those negotiations?
What potential interests does Iran have in
the US withdrawal from Afghanistan?" So the
military is taking in intelligence at every
single level and at various levels of detail
as well, to serve a vast need for information.
SIERRA: As a side note, it s worth mentioning
that since these interviews were recorded,
there has been an intense debate about the
role of intelligence in the U.S. withdrawal
from Afghanistan, as well as the future of
our intelligence capabilities in the region.
It s a deep and complex issue, and it could
be the topic of its own episode. We won t
be getting into it today, but you can find
a lot of related coverage on CFR.org if you
re interested.
SIERRA: Ok so to just go back to the President,
how does he or she receive and use intelligence?
HARDING: So the president, being the president,
gets to know anything he or she wants. Every
day the intelligence community puts together
what we call the book for the president. And
the book will include anywhere from five to
10 pieces that talk about strategic developments,
that talk about tactical developments, that
reveal what's going on around the world. The
president might spend an hour in the morning
working on the PDB and getting their intelligence
briefing. However, somebody like the DNI who's
now Avril Haines, their only job is working
on the business of intelligence.
SIERRA: The DNI, or Director of National Intelligence,
was a role created in 2004 to oversee and
centralize a complex network of U.S. intelligence
agencies. It was developed in response to
9/11. They are responsible for promoting the
sharing of information by easing institutional
and operational barriers.
HARDING: But it's still the president's intelligence
and he can have anything he wants. Really
each president crafts this process exactly
how he likes it. So President Obama, he really
enjoyed reading, so he would take his book
and actually do a lot of reading of the book
and do a lot of notes on it. President Trump
apparently was more into graphics and liked
graphic depictions of what was going on and
wanted to talk things through. President Bush,
the second President Bush, he was a voracious
consumer of intelligence. And he really liked
not only a really robust book to read, but
he liked to have conversations. So he would
actually invite analysts into the Oval to
have conversations about the pieces that they'd
written to do a deep dive on a particular
subject. So each president really shapes the
PDB the way that they most want to use it
and the way that's most useful for them.
SIERRA: That's a lot of power in one person's
hands to decide.
HARDING: It is.
SIERRA: What they hear and pay attention to.
HARDING: It is. And there's always this very
careful dance between telling the President
things that he's gonna be interested in or
they're gonna be useful, and then telling
him things that he really doesn't want to
hear. The story about telling truth to power,
that old adage, it's 100% true.
SIERRA: So do separate agencies ever produce
conflicting information?
HARDING: Yes. So this was one of the big takeaways
after 9/11 and also after the Iraq War. What
you want in the intelligence community is
not duplication, not redundancy, but a really
robust exchange of views. And it makes sense
for several agencies to be looking at the
same sets of data and then perhaps taking
different interpretations or competing interpretations.
One of the things that is required as an analyst
at CIA, is that before you write any piece,
you have to send your draft around to the
entire inter-agency, all the intelligence
agencies and say, Any comments? And if somebody
comes back and says, Well, I think you've
misinterpreted this point. Or I think that
you should adjust this language to be more
precise. Then you try your best to incorporate
all of those comments. But every once in a
while somebody will come back and say, I think
you've got this totally wrong, you're totally
missing the point here. Your analysis is bad.
And I think it's actually this instead. Then
we publish something called a dissent. And
that's really important for the intellectual
honesty of intelligence analysis. And also
just to let the policymaker know that there's
not one way to look at this.
SIERRA: A high-priority briefing could influence
a president s decision to take military action.
But intelligence also gets used in things
as seemingly innocuous as trade negotiations.
At the military level, a briefing might be
about something as granular as whether a bridge
can bear the weight of a tank crossing it,
and as far-reaching as nuclear security. The
flow has been there for a long time. But the
methods, challenges, and opportunities for
the intelligence community have been changing.
And to understand how spying really happens
these days, we have to start with the old
days of World War II and the Cold War that
followed. You know, the era of Russian and
American spies that inspired so many classic
novels and films. Tinker, Tailor, Soldier,
Spy: I suppose that s where it began, turning
my eyes to the East, oh so how trivial we
ve become as a nation, say mid-40s...
SIERRA: Can you give me a quick summary of,
sort of, the good old days of espionage?
LUCAS: In the old days, you could pretend
to be someone just by claiming to be them.
You could say I am so-and-so and if you spoke
the right language and had the right clothes
and seemed quite confident. It was quite hard
for any before the days of say, fingerprints,
and photographs, it was really quite hard
to check if someone wasn't who they said they
were. So perhaps the greatest British spy
ever, Paul Dukes happened to speak really,
really good Russian. And he turned up in Russia
after the revolution, and actually played
the piano in the canteen of the secret police
headquarters, which is a perfect place for
him to run his agents. He borrowed money from
British merchants who are still hanging on
there hoping that communism was temporary.
And he was perhaps the most successful British
spy ever. And everything he did would be completely
impossible now. Because he was able to bluff
his way into things where nowadays they'd
be saying, well, hang on where your documents?
How do you get into the country? Where's your
passport? All these all these questions. And
so the ability to pretend to be someone who
you're not, which is absolutely central to
espionage is getting harder all the time.
SIERRA: So you mentioned that things have
changed since the old days. And I want to
understand, why? So let's start with technology.
LUCAS: Technology means that we leave a kind
of digital snail's trail, everywhere we go,
you carry a mobile phone with you, probably
2 billion people in the world, have mobile
phones or access to them, carry them with
them all of the time, we live our lives on
social media, we have Instagram accounts and
LinkedIn, 750 million LinkedIn, 2 billion
on Facebook. And we have credit ratings. Very
particularly in the advanced industrial societies,
we pay with electronic money, credit cards,
for example, or online payments. And all this
leaves a kind of digital trail completely
innocent, in most cases, it's not particularly
interesting to know that I got up in the morning,
I went out, I bought a coffee with a card,
and I went swimming and didn't take my phone
with me. But I was no doubt caught on the
CCTV at the swimming place, and so on. But
you can put all these things together, and
they start building a very clear picture.
So you say, who is this person who doesn't
have a mobile phone? That's really surprising.
If someone has a mobile phone, then that's
basically a tracking beacon, you can say,
when's it been switched on last? Where do
they go? Even if you can't get access to the
actual calls and texts and things that they've
used the mobile phone for just as a geolocation
device, it's a really powerful tool. And the
absence of it is a really powerful tool. So
you put all these things together, and it
becomes really hard to be anonymous, particularly
if you then add the biometrics, the facial
recognition, the way in which you can make
a computer image of the way someone walks,
so-called gate analysis. And you just see
only one person, the world walks like that.
And he's walking down the street in Beijing
right now, and we want to know why, bang,
you know, that's a really powerful tool for
the counterintelligence people.
SIERRA: That's wild. I love that the technology
points out that if someone has a lack of presence
on those things, it's just as suspicious.
I feel the same way, when I look up someone
my friends are dating and I'm like, well,
they're not on these things, seem suspicious.
So I guess that translates all the way up
to this as well.
LUCAS: Yes, I mean, it used to be that it
was quite easy to create a sort of plausible
seeming identity, that would stand up to really
quite a lot of scrutiny. And now it's really
difficult if you turn up in Russia, or in
China, pretending to be someone you're not
the consequences of getting it wrong are catastrophic.
And the margin for error is very, very small.
SIERRA: Is it also that technology has provided
a cheaper, safer way of getting information?
LUCAS: Yes, one of the sort of sayings in
the Espionage world is that when one door
closes, another door opens. And we're able
to find out a lot more about our adversaries,
thanks to technology. So the sort of things
that Bellingcat has done, and they're not
an intelligence agency, that were kind of
private intelligence agency. But they've been
able to catch Russian spies by basically googling
and buying commercially available information.
And it's really impressive what you can do.
So this is clearly something that helps us
on the counterintelligence side. But in terms
of aggressive intelligence collection, if
you're trying to get alongside say, someone
in China who's got access to secrets when
you want to get hold of them in a way that
the Chinese authorities are never going to
find out. That is becoming really difficult.
It's not impossible, but it's really difficult.
SIERRA: And I would assume more dangerous.
LUCAS: Dangerous for them certainly, and in
fact that there was a very serious breach
in the CIA's communication software a few
years ago, which led to every single, it is
said, CIA assets in China being caught and
executed. Because the way that they had for
their agents to communicate, involved a brilliantly
thought out piece of kind of anonymous software.
But the trouble is, once the Chinese worked
out what it was, they were then able to spot
everyone who was using it. So the potential
for catastrophe is much, much higher And increasingly,
people are going for different ways of doing
intelligence rather than the old-fashioned
cover identity.
SIERRA: Are there specific ways that artificial
intelligence in particular is changing the
game?
LUCAS: Absolutely. Artificial Intelligence
is the secret sauce here because we've known
for ages that it's possible to collect huge
amounts of data. You hack into Facebook, and
you get the 2 billion Facebook accounts and
you can, presumably, the Chinese can do that.
What makes it really impressive is when you
look for the anomalies. And so you see, it's
put together that with the mobile phone database,
and lots of sort of Google searches. And I
want to find everyone who's been to China,
whose face appears under one account on Facebook,
and who is using a burner phone when they
come to China or something like that. And
that's the sort of thing that AI is really
good at spotting the oddities. And the oddities
may just be somebody lives a very odd life
and happens to use a different burner phone
every time they go on a foreign trip or happens
to like having Facebook identities that are
not their own. But on the whole, these oddities
are tremendously powerful clues for counter-intelligence
people. And the development of AI means we
get better and better at finding them in big
sets of data.
HARDING: So, Compute really is the future
of the intelligence enterprise. There will
never be a substitution for, you know, somebody
recruiting the exact right asset at the exact
right time, who's gonna tell you what the
adversary government is thinking. But, there
is so much information out there in the world
just sitting and waiting to be used and there
are some companies and corporations out there
who are already starting to compete with the
intelligence community on taking all the information
and compiling it in a usable form and that
is going to be I think, a competition challenge
for the IC. They're gonna have to figure out
what do we buy off the shelf from some of
these companies and then what do we try and,
and recreate in house ourselves and where
does the secret line really come in? So, in
my job right now I'm working on a whole set
of projects on how to make better use of what
you call open-source intelligence. And, this
is traditionally you know, like The New York
Times.
SIERRA:
Right.
HARDING:
Or you know, some kind of foreign broadcasting
services information. But, now it's much more
than that. It's the digital dust that's scattered
all over the internet and how can you lien
usable information from that digital dust.
I think that as we move forward, we're gonna
need those data scientists, we're gonna need
those coders, we're gonna need the really
super talented hackers who are just desperately
clever at getting around security constraints
and stealing the secrets that way. And there
just are not enough data scientists out there
to both feed the giant sucking sound in Silicon
Valley, and then also feed the US government
and specifically the intelligence community.
And, you know, speaking as a former government
employee, I think what we were always really
hoping for when I was hiring people, was that
the mission would be compelling and would
pull in the best talent.
SIERRA:
What do you see as the biggest intelligence
priorities for the US right now?
HARDING:
Like I said, the Russians are the Russians
and you gotta give a lot of respect to those
guys for the work that they've done, you know
my work on the 2016 election at the same time
as I really hate everything that they did,
you also gotta give them some grudging respect
for how well they did some of it.
I would say though that the number one intelligence
challenge for us right now is China. And,
that's because they are talented at what they
do. Their intelligence services are very talented.
But, they also have figured out a way to forcibly
co-opt huge percentages of their population
to help the state. So, if you're a Chinese
business, if you are a business based in China,
maybe you're not officially a state-owned
enterprise but, you know where your bread
is buttered and if the Chinese government
comes to you and says "I need A, B, and C."
Then you're gonna give it to them. So, I think
that, that China is both smart and well resourced
and we as Americans are just not used to the
concept that somebody who says they're here
to do business is also working on behalf of
the government and it's taken us a minute
to get smart on that and to really recognize
the threat.
SIERRA: It can be hard to know what to make
of all of this. As the 18 intelligence services
of the United States compete with parallel
organizations in places like Russia and China,
most of what happens remains secret. We know
from the past that there have been mistakes,
and even injustices, carried out in the name
of intelligence. On the other hand, we don
t have a way of knowing how many times tragedies
have been averted.
SIERRA:
So it seems like secrecy is the thing here.
So as everyday people, how can we assess the
value of espionage if we never get to know
the details and aren't really aware of the
results? Should we just trust that the world
has been saved without us knowing about it?
LUCAS:
Well, I think what you can certainly do is
question your elected representatives about
the amount of money that's going in. I think
that one can question the results in terms
of, is my country safer, and when there's
clearly something gone very badly wrong, as
it did with 9/11. You can say Well, hey, you
know, you're paid all this money to catch
these people. Why didn't you? And so after
the event, if something's gone wrong, it's
harder to ask when things have gone, right,
because obviously, the sources and methods
involved are quite precious and one doesn't
want to expose them. So in the end, as it
was so many things in a democratic society,
quite a lot has to be taken on trust. But
that doesn't mean you can't try and verify
it when the opportunity arises.
SIERRA:
What type of position do you think we would
be in as a country without this flow of intelligence?
HARDING:
I mean, a very difficult one. We'd be in a
very difficult position. This goes back to
George Washington and the very earliest days
of our country. And we talk about George Washington
as the earliest spymaster. He had a ring of
spies that were called the Culper Ring, during
the revolutionary war and they were letting
him know what the Brits were up to, where
they were moving, he had both that tactical
and that strategic intelligence. Today, I
mean, we're up against a Russian intelligence
service that is just as talented, if not more
so than they were in the Cold War. China has
figured out, not only how to run a top-notch
intelligence service, but then also how to
co-opt massive elements of society to help
those intelligence services do their work.
And then, you know, there are, there are other
top-notch intel services all over the world
and if we try to keep American interests strong
around the world without the insights provided
by the intelligence community, I think we
would have a very difficult time trying to
keep up with these other nations, but then
just trying to anticipate threats and preempt
them before they happen. We talk a lot in
the spy game about how, you know, a good day
is when the bad thing does not happen because
you warned ahead of time and it was prevented
by good policies. Usually, you know, what
gets out in the press is when the bad thing
actually does happen and the intelligence
has failed, but we, we really enjoy the good
days when something that could've been a problem
is no longer a problem because we warned about
it ahead of time.
SIERRA: Hey listeners, so our summer intern
Sophie Yass is heading back to school and
we will miss her dearly. In honor of her last
day here, here she is reading us out.
YASS: Thanks Gabby! For resources used in
this episode and more information, visit CFR.org/whyitmatters
and take a look at our show notes. Have a
question, some feedback, just want to say
hey? Send us an email at whyitmatters@cfr.org.
Subscribe to the show on Apple Podcasts, Spotify,
Stitcher, or wherever you get your audio.
And if you re a fan, we d love it if you could
leave us a review. Ideally a good one, it
really does help, and we really appreciate
it. Why It Matters is a production of the
Council on Foreign Relations. The show is
created and produced by Asher Ross, Jeremy
Sherlick, and Gabrielle Sierra. Our sound
designer is Markus Zakaria. Rafaela Siewert
is our associate podcast producer. This Summer
s intern was me, Sophie Yass. Robert McMahon
is our Managing Editor, and Doug Halsey is
our Chief Digital Officer. Extra help for
this episode was provided by John Masters
and Kali Robinson. Original music is composed
by Ceiri Torjussen. Special thanks go to Richard
Haass and Jeff Reinke. For Why It Matters,
this is Sophie Yass signing off. Thanks for
listening.